i wanted to tell you guys about this
little project called the advice of
strangers.com my friend mark is living
his entire month of november by the
advice of strangers on his website he
asks questions and you guys vote on the
things that he should do the other day i
got to take over and make all of the
questions and with the help of you guys
we decided what mark did for the day i
wanted to share with you guys a lot of
the crazy things that happened that day
and be sure to check out the
advicestrangers.com and help mark live
the rest of november
oh my god you made it
this is really awesome this is pete pete
with a camera hi how are you i'm good
okay watch the foosball table hi
it's good i'm tired i'm this project is
exhausting me
i'm so tired i'm excited i'm sweaty what
do you got
a musical right a car wash
something to do with ballet how do you
feel about this great
that's great we'll put it up okay pretty
much what most people were suggesting
they really want you to dance in an
apple store but i think we should let
them pick hey
sorry oh god there's no swearing aloud
um the swearing poll has ended did you
realize that there's 14 small faces that
i have to draw on your body now should
we do it in crayola or sharpie i'm
thinking sharpie in an executive
decision are you okay with that i think
i'm okay with that
14 swear words so far and this is going
on throughout the day so here we go
they're getting bigger
okay so we're about to take a ballet
class um learn some some fundamentals of
ballet is that what we enjoy
we're gonna try some basic moves some
basic positions and we'll see how it
goes mark are you excited
yes i'm excited yes of course
i'm terrified of dancing though i have a
tremendous fear of dancing you know
oh that's beautiful open
it's
our other shoulder and arm is coming
around
i mean i just i just did one no no i
think you should try it again i'm really
not i'm no you feel great okay go ahead
you look like you're rapping you look
like you're like you're like tell them
yo yo so i'm spinning in this guy's
apartment
no you've got all the right elements
though it's just that they're not
coordinated yeah
where are we going
where are we going to the apple store we
are because we were voted to go
well actually
oh yeah you made a decision i did but a
lot of people wanted you to dance at the
apple store okay and since you haven't
seen here that justine does a lot
is dan central
i do yeah so that i'm following you in
this in this action and since i have a
fear of dancing
i thought what better place to go than
you know to publicly help you get over
your fears
cool though i mean i think that's that's
no it's good should be good i'm ready
i'm already nervous actually thank you
i'm starting it a little oh gosh i'm
getting goosebumps i think it's the
energy drinks
no it's it's
yeah i don't know here i found a stamp
i'm gonna give that to you thank you
i'm warming up i'm practicing
okay
should we get a quick beer
no
we can't
i need to be clear and focused
okay the apple store dance was
successful mark did a wonderful job and
we used a lot of our ballet skills that
we learned this morning how do you think
it went i think it was great yeah i
think we did a fantastic high five to
the internet
it's pretty good is it called vibrato
vibrato is that
a little more of that you like that yeah
you just
okay get up through the diaphragm
let's see
so mark is getting ready to go in there
and there you guys chose
i really wanted to auto tune it
the question is are you ready i'm ready
okay
yes
yes please
all right here it goes uh i've already
started recording so we are we're going
okay here goes
i would like
okay i wanted to join in but i was like
no this is your
and i don't think it came out right no i
think it was good i mean we can do like
uh we can do one more thing one thing
okay yeah okay so how does it go
okay so how are you feeling right now in
non-opera and not opera good yeah that
was really way out of my comfort zone
yeah i got a little nervous not gonna
lie but you did really good because not
only did you sing right you danced in
public again that's your third time
today
it's time to watch some cars
it is time to wear some cars
gotta go the car wash
needs to get at least two cars to let
him
wash their car
in a king costume and with a pair of
underwear so this is gonna be pretty
pretty awesome
where are we gonna do it just right yeah
he's bottled water yeah just say free
car wash and stand on the corner yeah
that's perfect okay
yep i need those undies yep right here
are you ready for this yeah okay i want
at least two cars washed
um we don't have much time because it's
gonna get dark so we need to get these
cars washed
and uh
yeah it's free too don't forget i'm
trying to fill these letters in it's not
really working out so there we go
that's a good sign
where's my method here
what do i do this is hard
it's not putting forth enough effort i
feel like we should have probably
stopped the dollar store got some
glitter and really went all out this is
tough
all right i just don't think anybody
wants a car's wash today look at this
guy this bike
all right free bike wash
there's no other bike washers
free cars
free
i'm so proud of you i don't this is all
i got
it's free though
wait is he oh he's he watching his car
too
i don't know it doesn't matter
i got two i got two customers
oh wait were you just waiting
maybe you weren't here for the free car
wash
okay you're off
great work oh my gosh thank you it's
very environmental friendly like i
haven't even used a whole bottle of
water
pepper i hope you don't need these back
dude
i was voted to do this project i'm doing
called the advice of strangers i post
questions every day and people vote me
to do certain things and today
justine over there took over
what was the poll
we're voting on what he was gonna wear
okay and what he was going to watch the
cars with so
this is this is what we ended up okay
i'm going to want to wash my hands a lot
after this
that was two people
meaningful the one wasn't actually here
no he wasn't but he was in the space
good work
dirty high five
just just leave us a
good review on yelp
okay
hope you guys enjoyed the video be sure
to check out the advice of strangers.com
and help mark live the rest of november
that's it see you guys later bye